CCUS19 - Battles of the Civil War
Hi, I’m John Green and this is Crash Course
US History.
Starting next week, we’re going to be talking
about the Civil War.
As you may have noticed, Crash Course doesn’t
usually focus on military history, because
we’re more interested in causes and effects
and that kind of stuff, but because some in
our audience are likely to insist that a series
on American History has to include the battles
of the Civil War, I am now going to tell you
about EVERY SINGLE fight of the war.
Oh.
Stan, this says there were 8,000 instances
of violence between the Union and the Confederate
States of America between 1861 and 1865.
Can that be right?
Slight change of plan.
I’m going to tell you about the MAJOR battles
of the Civil War.
The shooting started in 1861.
In April the first shots of the war were fired
at the Battle of Fort Sumter, South Carolina,
which the South won.
Next the Battle of Rich Mountain went to the
North.
First Bull Run happened in Manassas, VA in
July.
The South won, General Jackson got the nickname
Stonewall, and the North realized this war
was going to be serious business.
The South had another victory at Wilson’s
Creek in August, but lost to the Union at
Carnifex Ferry in September.
The North got another win at the Battle of
Cheat Mountain, but the South finished the
year strong with wins at Ball’s Bluff and
Chustenahlah.
The North came roaring back in 1862 with wins
at the battles of Mill Springs, Fort Henry,
Roanoke Island, and Fort Donelson, where the
Confederate general was named Simon Bolivar
Buckner.
What!?
There was fighting in the west, with the South
winning at Valverder, NM, and Pea Ridge, AR.
The Union won at New Madrid, MO.
The Battle of Hampton Roads, VA in March was
a draw, and featured the first fight between
two ironclad warships, the USS Monitor and
the CSS Virginia.
The Union won the Battle of Bern, and the
first battle of Kernstown, and then draws
at Glorieta Pass, NM, and Yorktown.
The Union won the Battle of Shiloh, where
future Ben Hur author Lew Wallace was accused
of incompetence and cowardice.
The Union won the Battle of Fort Pulaski and
the Battle of Forts Jackson and St Philip,
which gave the North control of New Orleans.
The North won the siege of Corinth, and McClellan
fought one of the many indecisive battles
he would be involved in at Williamsburg, VA.
Then Stonewall Jackson had a great run, winning
battles at McDowell, Front Royal, and Winchester.
Union forces captured Memphis, TN in May,
but then lost a couple more to Jackson at
Cross Keys and Port Republic.
In Virginia that June, Robert E Lee and Goerge
McClellan fought a series of six battles in
seven days, which were called the seven days
battles.
There was a draw at Oak Grove, Union victory
at Beaver Dam Creek, a win for Lee at Gaines’
Mill, ties at Garnett’s and Golding’s
Farm, the Battle of Savage’s Station, and
the battle of Glendale.
The Union finally won the Seven Days at Malvern
Hill, but McClellan withdrew after the battle,
allowing Lee and the remaining confederates
to escape.
In July 1862, one of the least consequential
battles of the war took place in Stan’s
hometown, Newburgh, IN.
A force of 35 Confederate irregulars built
some fake cannons out of stovepipes that they
called Quaker guns, crossed the Ohio River,
captured some weapons and a hospital full
of wounded Union soldiers, and then abandoned
the town later the same day.
This was the first town in the North to be
captured by Confederates.
Later that summer came the Battles of Baton
Rouge, Cedar Mountain, Mannassas Station,
the Second Battle of Bull Run, Richmond, KY,
Chantilly, and Harper’s Ferry, all of which
the Confederates won.
The Union won at South Mountain, but lost
at Munfordville.
On September 17 McClellan ended Lee’s invasion
of the north at Anteitam, MD.
This was the bloodiest single day of the war
with 22,717 dead, wounded, or missing.
The rest of 1862 saw the battles of Perryville,
Prairie Grove, Fredericksburg, and Chickasaw
Bayou.
1863 started in Tennessee with a Union victory
at the Battle of Stones River, but also with
a simultaneous Confederate victory at Galveston,
TX.
There were lots of smallish skirmishes during
the winter and early Spring, until the Battle
of Chancellorsville in May, where Lee defeated
Hooker, but Stonewall Jackson was mortally
wounded.
He lost his arm, and then died 8 days later
of pneumonia.
His arm buried with its own headstone near
Chancellorsville.
The North won a bunch of battles in Mississippi
at Port Gibson, Raymond, Jackson, Champion
Hill, Big Black River Ridge, and finally,
Vicksburg.
This victory, along with the victory at Port
Hudson effectively ended the Confederacy’s
ability to use the Mississippi River.
June, 1863 in Virginia was inconclusive, with
draws at Brandy Station, Winchester, Aldie,
Middleburg, and Upperville.
July brought the Battle of Gettysburg, a major
Union victory.
This battle featured Pickett’s famous charge,
was the end of Lee’s second invasion of
the north, was the costliest of the war in
terms of caualties, and led to, believe it
or not, The Gettysburg Address.
The rest of that summer brought split results
with Union wins at Helena, AR, Honey Springs,
OK and Chattanooga, TN.
The Confederates answered with two victories
at Ft Wagner, SC.
They also won at Ft Sumter AGAIN, holding
the fort against heavy Union bombardment,
and they perpetrated a massacre of civilians
in Lawrence, KS.
The rest of 1863 saw battles at Sabine Pass,
TX, Bayou Fourche, AR, a major confederate
win at Chickamauga, the battles of Bristow
Station, Wauhatchie, Rappahannock Station,
Chattanooga again, Ringgold Gap, Fort Sanders,
and Mossy Creek.
Oh man, we’re only to 1864.
Gotta keep it moving.
Stan, can you just indicate who won these
on screen?
Great
The first major battles of 1864 were in February
at Olustee, FL and Okolona, MS.
The spring saw battles at Fort De Russy, Mansfield,
Prairie D’Ane, AR, Pleasant Hill, LA, and
Fort Pillow, TN.
There were The Battles of the Wilderness,
Spottsylvania Courthouse, Procter’s Creek,
New Market, North Anna, Old Church, Cold Harbor,
and the Battle of the Piedmont all in Virginia.
Summer brought the battles of Marietta, GA,
and Brice’s Crossroads, MS.
The battles of Trevillian Station, Petersburg,
Lynchburg, and Jerusalem Plank Road were all
fought in Virginia.
Also Kennesaw Mountain, GA, Monocacy, Maryland,
and Fort Stevens, in the District of Columbia.
Abraham Lincoln himself went to observe this
battle, and the guy standing next to him got
shot.
Next were the battles of Tupelo, MS, Peachtree
Creek, GA, and Atlanta, GA, a major Union
victory won by General Sherman.
Also fought were the battles of Kernstown,
VA, Ezra Church, GA, the Battle of the Crater
in Virginia, the battles of Mobile Bay, AL,
Deep Bottom, Globe Tavern, and Reams station
in VA, and the battle of Jonesborough, GA
which solidified Union control of Atlanta.
Ok.
Autumn of 1864, we’re in the home stretch
here.
The battles of Opequon, Fisher’s Hill, Chaffin’s
Farm, Peebles’ Farm, and Cedar Creek were
all fought in Virginia.
The battles of Byram’s Ford, Newtonia, and
Westpory all happened in Missouri.
Johnsonville, TN, Griswoldville, GA, Spring
Hill, TN, The Sand Creek Massacre, The Battle
of Franklin, TN, Fort McAllister, GA, and
Nashville, TN finished out the year.
Whew.
1865, here we go.
The Battles of Fort Fisher, NC, Hatcher’s
Run, VA, Waynesboro, Virginia, Bentonville,
NC, Fort Stedman, VA, Spanish Fort, AL, White
Oak Road, VA, Five Forks, VA, Selma, AL, the
THIRD battle of Petersburg, VA, Fort Blakely,
AL, Saylor’s Creek, VA, Appomattox Station,
VA, and finally, the decisive battle at Appomattox
Courthouse, VA, on April 8, 1865 which resulted
in Lee’s surrender to Grant.
There were a few more minor skirmishes, but
the war was OVER.
So there you have it, an episode of Crash
Course ENTIRELY about battles.
I know that we missed many, many battles of
the war, but these are most of the big ones.
There’s not even a big finish this week,
because I’m just exhausted from all the
fighting.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you next
week.